[音楽]
持って
me
んをっん
みなさんこんにちはう
京料理の時間がやってまいりましたそれでは講師を紹介いたします
平宮だけは生で増え命之介先生です
今日1
[音楽]
よろしく
先生今日は何を作っていただけるのでしょうねええ
滑っ
ミクじゃ
肉じゃがありがとうございました今日はですねまぁターンした特に大好きなんじゃない
でしょうか
高級車がピラニアだけはなので食えねえの試験先生の行く店
こうだということでって早速うんいいじゃんの先生安心発症が食えねえのスキャンのみ
ジャガーを今日は
作っていただけるということでよろしくお願いします
はい
かわいいよはいというわけで今回肉じゃがを作っているわけなんですけども
インド人完全無視カレーというものをご存知でしょうか
家以上にこういうのがあります
インド人アドバイスは完全メッセして作ったカレーがあります裏にはもう完全さんの
アドバイスを正確したのに無視された形の画像も載っておりまあなるほどガン無視すが
max になっていますね
で私ベタベタ感あるんですけどこれすごいのが本当に美味しいんですよええ
まずで美味しいこれ逆に僕は逆の発想で例えば2曲だといえば
おふくろの味っていう意味
以上ありませんありますねはいですよね逆にお袋に僕にくじゃあなぜないですめっちゃ
もらったんですよねにを含むからに来ればたアドバイスめっちゃ払ったんで今日それを
全部完全無視してオフこのからのアドバイスを完全に無視して逆のことをするくらいの
なるほどですね完全に星して肉皿を作ればすごい美味しいカレーずじゃぁつけるんじゃ
ないかなと思いまして
おふくろのアドバイス完全無視肉じゃがをね作ってみようかなと思っておりますある
ほどですね
今日は家族でお願いしますはいでて準備が整ったようですので早速
肉じゃがを作って頂ければと思いますお願いします分かります作っていきましょうはい
準備するものは
じゃがいも玉ねぎ人参牛肉白滝あなたはプラッだし汁を醤油
美人パイさとまぁここらへんがベースとしてあるんですけどまぁ母親のアドバイスに
よっては使わないものも出てきますのでこっからちょっと臨機応変になるほどっていき
ましょう
いうわけで実質レシピナスといった感じですねまずジャガイモを切りましょう
はいどれかじゃないですねえぇコレですね災害を使っていきましょうはいまず上がって
いきます
はい
でしょうかじゃがいも見えていきましょうはいピラーが入らないですね
a でっいかないとどうなるんですかこのまま使えないですねそれから包丁であれ校長
もなんですか包丁あるんですよ
実はねハートロスご意見でしょ
新じゃがバーカバーカなくてもいけるかもちろんやてぃ
の新坂ですかね沈着じゃないですもう実質信者がですね
調べた結果ですねばジャガイモの芽には天然毒素が多く含まれている
最悪の場合死亡例あり全部皮むきましょう
これがなければ便がなければ逆に彼は自体には中栄予算あるらしいですけど
はいと受けて次に民族って言うんですけど入ったすぐにピーターがないとちょっと
難しいのでまずピラー会にどうぞ
料理番組で p やー戒律
ません
ああ
早速人情味ていきますはい
あーどっしーすばらすぃ
やつ大に切っていきましょうお願いしますよ
me
時で玉ねぎ言われましたあ全然まだでした
ちゅっちきましたこれをこれから切っていきますはいお願いします
同7あペラペラペラペラペロペロ
須郷イヤーや畑へ
あーなてない全然大丈夫じゃない人なんだよなんだよなんでー
はいいかがでしょうか次はシラー木を準備しましょう
白滝ですねあの国から離さのアドバイスがありますつきました
おふくろワンポイントアドバイス仰ら時ははい結んであるやつを使いなさいとこれは
ちょっと結んだりやつなんですけどもうありを聞くとあのその糸こんな
バラバラになるのはちょっと嫌だけど
[音楽]
今からこの結んでやるしらたきを拭いていきますはいマナーいうことを破るってやっ
ほぉ da
me
焼いてあったねーいや並みにサード挙げてみましょう
はい the 油を入れてきます小さじ2杯です
オーバーしたけれでボカシ魂って本当にでねしていきました
まずは羽根な体だったので水ちょっと入ってラックわー
まずだけでジャガー
スって落ち着きましたね全部かけてるんですけどなんでなんで焦げてる
ジャガー中でダメだったのです
これがまあ二さあがクッソブルー
た
油を間違えていました失礼致しましたちゃんとしゃべらでやっていきました開閉はまず
玉ねぎを炒めていきましょう
配布はまずうまそうだろ大丈夫にも玉ねぎを炒めてるわけなんですけどもうここで母
からのワンポイントアドバイスここで本来ならにこいつに入れてい食べましてぜひが私
の版あるなどばですよ肉ではなく acorn を支えるというアドバイスを頂いて
おります
俺がなんかうちのミックジャガーの特徴でにいくつか多いんですよキラキラの薄切り
カー
ブロックの小さいベーコンでジグザグを作ると言っているのでが虫まあすぐ闘争を聞く
も食べれないんで米公も無理だす肉も無理だと
こちらのほかチーズかまぼこを使っていこうと思います以上私魚なら食べれますので
ベーコンでもなんかに空なんかチーズかまぼこを使ってに行くザロック
ていこうと思います
th
やっほー
ここでまた前ワンポイントアドバイスでございますじゃがいもにんじんは行ってかな
眺めにレンジでチンしてから使うらしいですこれは時間短縮と煮崩れ防止のためらしい
ですね
いやねーけどなぁ
風景で子どもがいれていきましょう曲ではいじゃあ全部見えてきますわー
じゃあ全部入れていきます
[音楽]
ぜひ食べていきますはい
ってここで半からのワンポイントアドバイス玉ねぎ炒めて皿いもにんじんを炒めた時に
砂糖を入れる様子このタイミングで効果で入れることによって動かさないようになる
らしいです
ああ
いいだけじゃねえんだけど佐藤の真逆の存在し用ズームしました
一応このタイプにしよう投入していきましょうすごい
me
はいじゃあ鯖その身差を投入していきます始めます
されています
あのメインじゃないか堂々沸騰ですか素晴らしいと思いませ本当に行く坂の上羽生まれ
て初めて作ったチーズ感を覚えていきました
ok このうちにみりんを入れていきます今でも
もうちょい
これを袋から衝撃の技ですえっと水を入れて煮ているときにお醤油を入れるらしいです
なるほどですね多分風味が凍ってるよね
あーですです備前へ
性への逆といえばこちらソースでございます
代わりに彼が目指すってカオスですいやいい味付けになると思うよねー
[音楽]
re
はいしかしに行くじゃんだよな
結局弁護士て何ですそれでにポッカレモンも入れてみましょうか
でもんか台座気がするね北海道できはなくん
これ以上袋からのアドバイスはすべて以前無視しました
はい
先生
ブービーいくの原因が虫こっちずパティ以降ん棚2
v うーん早速いただく場所関係でキロ紹介
普通に叔父が気になるところではある数回して井坂そうだな
スープやで開封いただきますはいいただけます
[音楽]
大丈夫だまだわからまだなあのスープは素性が飾りすぎ birds ソースネクター
はちょっと本当は味味が一番大事だから味を館内では端部分がただあるので味を重点的
に感じていただきたいでござる
あっ
どうですかはずの方
あのーんんペップとだまず僕は汚すですね
まあですかあのチェックをしっとりしてあったりして
思うんですよ
私も食べてみるまた効果等をた僕なんですよ
どうかい
うんはいですねなんかソースがあってますねとの声が場内には入ったら
一つ入れたん
チーズかまぼこがクソ不味い味であってるつくりました高
まだですっております多分キュレーションん
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ